emmanuel macron only did one campaign
rally but the man who brands himself a
centrist did enough to have a chance of
being the first incumbent french
president in 20 years to win a second
term
again though he'll have to beat the far
right
to our fellow citizens that abstained or
voted for the extreme either because
they are angry against inequalities or
to the ecological chaos or insecurity or
the difficulty of living in dignity even
working hard i will convince you in the
days to come
his opponent in the second round of
voting will again be marine le pen
leader of the national rally its
manifesto includes a promise to make it
illegal for muslim women to wear
headscarves in public places
your vote depends all over the french
territory on the legitimate
preponderance of the french culture and
language the customs of our regions and
the french way of life on republican
laws and values
le pen might pick up votes from
supporters of eric zemor another extreme
right candidate the former tv pundit has
asked his supporters to back her in the
second round
the far left's jean-luc melenchon had
hoped that this time he might make it to
the runoff but again he didn't quite get
enough votes
france's traditional right and left-wing
parties continue to hemorrhage support
the conservative the republicans party
and the valerie peckress saw their share
of the vote collapsed to single digits
the socialists and anne hidalgo have
been all but wiped out their share of
the vote barely registered
the beneficiary of those former
conservative and socialist votes seems
again to be macron
we actually ask the french voters to
support actually a strong european
france for the next turn of the
elections in two weeks
i believe we have a good record and we
have a worked out plan with a vision for
the future for the young our country and
for the workers
to the left macron has promised higher
pensions and more staff in health care
for the right thousands more police
officers and judges and a rise in the
retirement age from 62 to 65. going into
the second round emmanuel macron could
again benefit from the same republican
front that helped him easily beat marine
le pen back in 2017 that is most of the
losing candidates tonight have urged
their supporters not to let in the
extreme right it'll be difficult for
marine le pen to overcome that voting
block
bernard smith al jazeera paris